[Musique]
d'abord je voudrais vous dire que c'est
un très grand honneur pour moi d'être
avec vous aujourd'hui
merci beaucoup d'avoir trouvé un moment
pour nous malgré votre emploi du temps
très chargé
merci c'est un plaisir pour moi aussi
mon emploi du temps est en effet assez
chargé même c'est la plupart des
théâtres du monde sont fermés nous
continuons à travailler les conditions
sont un peu hors du commun avec
seulement 25% des spectateurs dans la
salle
avant c'était 50 % mais je peux dire
qu'on n'a pas vraiment ressenti que la
salle était à moitié vide car il y avait
quand même un certain nombre de
personnes et cette énergie étaient
présentes les dirigeants désormais nous
aurons pas sac pour cent jusqu'à la mi
janvier
espérons que cela ne durera pas
longtemps aviez vous déjà eu cette
expérience
non jamais lorsque vous êtes en train de
danser remarquez-vous le public où elle
vous aveugler par les projecteurs
normalement la salle et dans le noir on
n'est pas dans le noir mais il fait
sombre et nous sommes aveuglés par la
lumière des projecteurs comme da donc je
peux normalement voir les spectateurs
pendant l'entracte ou lors des saluts
après les spectacles normalement je ne
fais que les ressentir
je sens leur énergie leur regard et
attention
j'entends quand les spectateurs font du
bruit si quelque chose est tout mais si
un téléphone a sonné et qu'il ya une
certaine baisse d'attention mais le plus
souvent c'est un silence complet la
tension très forte focaliser sur la
scène évidemment c'est très important
point si je comprends bien en plus d
émotion de l'atmosphère de ces choses
évidentes
il y a aussi des différences techniques
en fonction des différentes scènes
n'est ce pas oui il ya certaines
différences de taille d'inclinaison la
scène peut être plate
le public ne se rend presque pas content
surtout des différences de degré
d'inclinaison
la scène peut être tellement incliné et
si l'on met une balle comme ça elle
roule tout simplement s'arrêter en
direction des spectateurs
elle roule directement dans la fosse
d'orchestre il arrive que ce soit moins
inclinée au que la scène soit tout à
fait plaque sans encline aisons
cantonales chacun utilise son bagage
scolaire ce qu'il a appris pour savoir
tenir bien son dos son corps ces sceaux
s'est jeté pour que le ce soit aulas la
technique est déjà très différents ont
recours à d'autres astuces c'est
beaucoup plus difficile
oui c'est beaucoup plus difficile de
danser sur une selle en guinée le
spectateur ne s'aperçoit de rien mais
vos orteils
oui normalement le spectateur est
surpris si la danseuse commence le
fouetter à un point et le termine à un
autre il n'y pas pas manche c'est aussi
en manque de formation parce qu'on
apprend ça à l'école comment tenir le
dos sur une scène inclinée
comment obtenir le dossier mais tout de
même très souvent si la ballerine est
emporté vers le bas c'est la cause d'une
forte inclinaison de la scène ont unifié
de venise voilà pourquoi nous avons
vraiment besoin de répéter quand nous
faisons une performance dans un nouveau
théâtre
nous devons absolument tester la scène
la scène peut être plus haut qu'au plus
sur le linoléum peut parfois être trop
glissant donc il faut s'habituer à être
seul à s'adapter cela peut définir par
exemple la dureté des pointes que je
vais mettre indien dans nos spectacles
nous vivons une époque folle kavi bleus
qu'ovide les mesures de sécurité c'est
devenu une grande épreuve
est ce difficile de rester en forme
qu'est-ce qui vous aide vous savez quand
nos collègues de la scala était déjà
fermée depuis un mois nous continuons à
travailler et tout le monde était
surpris par le fait qu'ils étaient chez
eux alors que nous dieu merci nous
travaillons ce sort nous est arrivé
également le premier mois je me rappelle
c'était un cauchemar surtout à cause de
ce manque d'information quand on ne sait
pas si on nous avait dit vous allez
rester chez vous pendant quatre mois et
après on sort on recommence petit à
petit a travaillé ça aurait été une
chose
quand nous étions tous vous comme nous
devant nos télés comme la totalité du
pays a atteint dans la fin du
confinement
alors quand le prolonger encore et
encore il y avait donc une nervosité une
vacillations oui vous savez vous savez
ce qui a été le plus difficile c'est que
nous comprenions que cela pouvait se
terminer à tout moment et qu'il faudrait
revenir la salle et être en forme
personne ne savait que ça durerait
autant personne ne savait qu'on
donnerait encore un mois pour nous
adapter pour retrouver une forme normale
bien sûr tout le monde faisait des
exercices à la maison bien sûr tout le
monde doit faire face à des conditions
différentes
les premiers temps on voyait toutes
sortes de blagues sur internet
les artistes de balle et non seulement
russes mais aussi étrangers les premiers
à être confiné montrer qu'il se tenait à
la cuisinière à l'évier de la cuisine
quelqu'un a essayé de faire quelque
chose sur un tout petit espace comme ça
pour faire des exercices et garder la
forme au début ça nous a fait rire
c'était rigolo mais au bout d'un moment
alors que tout se prolonger encore et
encore
la tension monte à l'intérieur
la tension monte et horriblement je me
souviens que pendant le premier mois de
confinement passé à la maison avec des
entraînements à la maison on ressentait
une grande peur qu'est ce qui vous a
fait tenir
heureusement j'ai de bonnes conditions
chez moi pour m'entraîner à gagner mais
j'ai des miroirs une barre de danse et
le monsieur m'a offert du linoléum on
l'a d'ailleurs distribué ensuite à tous
les codecs
c'est comme celui qu'on trouve dans les
cuisines un peu partout c'est un
linoléum spéciale oui c'est un linoléum
qu'on trouve sur scène et dans les
salles de répétition
donc ils ont coupé des énormes morceaux
de lure rouleau et en ont distribué à
chacun un médecin quand chaque soliste
analystes à partir du deuxième mois nous
avions tous ensemble des réunions sur
vous tous les matins et les enseignants
du bolchoï organisé pour nous les cours
du matin comme ça nous avons maintenu le
niveau l'énergie oui oui personnellement
je m'entraînais entre 2h et 3h30 par
jour j'ai même fait du pilates
j'ai commencé à utiliser des ballons
d'exercices à faire de la musculation
avec un élastique chose que je n'avais
jamais fait auparavant
et aujourd'hui la charge que j'ai est
suffisante en octobre a eu lieu la
première du ballet gabrielle chanel à
saint pétersbourg je vois d'ailleurs que
votre belle tenue et de chez chanel si
je me trompe pas oui je m'attendais à ce
qu'on en parle et vous avez deviné c'est
un ballet biographie à quel point est il
difficile de jouer un rôle pareil que
tout le monde connaît quand les gens
peuvent lire ou voir si cela correspond
ou pas il faut donc donner de l'émotion
et des informations ou est ce que dans
le cas du ballet ce n'est pas essentiel
il ne peut y avoir que des allusions à
louviers
vous savez et s'est avéré que nous en
savions très peu sur la créatrice de la
maison chanel
gabrielle chanel et pour être honnête
avant de commencer à travailler sur ce
personnage et ce spectacle je ne mettais
pratiquement pas intéressé à sa
personnalité
c'est une maison de mode
nous achetons des sacs des chaussures
des vêtements tout cela coûte très cher
tout cela est très beau cela montre que
la personne peut se le permettre parce
que un effet cela coûte très cher qu'est
ce qui vous a en particulier attirer
dans son destin
actu mots je dis cela parce que sa
marque et elles sont pour moi deux
choses différentes
quand j'ai commencé à creuser dans sa
vie à chercher voir lire ses mémoires
je suis allé à paris pour visiter son
appartement rue cambon j'ai vu
l'ambiance on m'a amenée voir je ne me
rappelle pas oh ça se trouve c'est plus
proche de la banlieue de paris il ya un
énorme centre où la maison chanel
conserve les grandes collections depuis
celle créée par chanel elle même jusqu'à
celle de karl lagerfeld qui a continué
ses collections et on peut y voir le
premier flacon du parfum chanel numéro 5
d'ailleurs cette année il fête ses 100
ans
tout cela est intéressant tous les
bijoux qu'elle a créée ça a été une
atmosphère particulière et un voyage
intéressant pour moi donc pour un
artiste de balle et il est également
nécessaire de faire connaissance avec le
personnage cela vous a aidé bien sûr
surtout quand on danse un personnage
vivant c'est à dire quelqu'un qui a
vraiment existé
il est très important de le comprendre
d'un être imprégné de ressentir quand
j'ai lu ses mémoires tant de choses ont
bougé dans ma tête j'ai vu d'un côté à
quel point cette femme étaient fortes
ambitieuses prête à tout faire pour
réaliser son but
d'un autre côté c'était une petite femme
si vulnérable qui est finalement resté
tout seul qui a pendant toute sa vie et
mais quand on autorise nous
et tant de fois tombée amoureuse elle
offrait son amour elle est venue dans ce
monde tout seul
et l'âne est parti tout seul dans sa
solitude la plus totale même si elle
tombe amoureuse facilement et était
entouré de gens incroyablement
intéressant voici quels personnages à
l'été j'ai compris que derrière toute
cette ouverture cette opulence et avait
une vulnérabilité une fragilité
incroyable un manque de protection en
elle un manque de protection
ce ballet a été mis en scène à partir de
zéro d'abord il n'y avait rien ni
livrées ni musique ni chorégraphie il y
a des mousses qui a spécialement écrit
la musique et youri passe ou cov a mis
en scène la chorégraphie et quand
l'image a commencé à se former
quand j'ai vu que la chorégraphie était
prête
j'ai commencé à le ressentir à le vivre
surtout quand j'étais déjà en costume et
empirer en allant sur scène il arrivait
que je ressente une immense douleur au
moment de séparation glv vraiment la vie
de chanel je peux au moins imaginer ce
que ça coûte de tenir tout cet empire de
continuer à créer de garder la tête
haute malgré tout alors que dans sa vie
elle a nord a traversé des hauts et des
bas vous avez dansé sur les meilleures
scènes vous avez ce titre ou pour le
dire plus correctement le statut des
toiles de la scala l'étoile c'est un mot
français je pense qu'il est utilisé dans
son sens propre ressentez vous une
différence en regardant vos collègues
étrangers
l'école russe de balai est elle
différente pour ce qui est des approches
des formes trop de gens bien du côté
plus émotionnel bien sur tous les
théâtres sont différents les compagnies
sont différentes les écoles même si on
considère moscou et saint pétersbourg il
ne faut pas chercher très loin il y à de
grandes différences mais en même temps
maintenant c'est tout un mélange je ne
vois plus de différences importantes
entre moscou et saint pétersbourg parce
que les générations se succèdent les
standards change ça et vous lui avez
vous besoin de vous adapter à cela
apprendre de nouvelles techniques da oui
bien sûr surtout quand j'étais jeune
danseuse et je me rendais dans de
différents endroits pour la première
fois j'avais envie de prouver à tout le
monde que j'étais au niveau que j'avais
le droit de danser au grand opéra parce
que l'école française est absolument
différente de l'école russe que je cours
et je voulais être au niveau
c'est-à-dire sans perdre de ce que
j'avais appris en russie
et apprendre de nouvelles choses auprès
des français et où que j'aille j'ai
toujours appris de nouvelles choses
ce bagage que j'ai appris pendant toutes
ces années
option vous êtes une artiste universel
oui j'étais prête à entrer sur scène
avec un partenaire reconnu après
seulement quelques répétitions
cela aussi on l'a appris quand il ya
très peu de répétitions
il faut faire tout soi-même il faut être
suffisamment stables sur ses pieds pour
que n'importe quel partenaire
même s'il est mauvais ne puisse modifier
votre mouvement il faut savoir tout
faire tout seul être légère pratiquement
se tait tout seul sur l'épaule de son
partenaire sans être aidé se soulever de
par ses propres efforts j'ai eu de
diverses situations dans la vie j'ai eu
des partenaires excellent et d'autres
pas vraiment surtout que vous ne pouvez
pas dire la personne que vous avez perdu
un peu l'équilibré mais que ce n'est pas
de ma faute
oui parce que cette personne nous a fait
perdre l équilibre on ne peut pas dire
ça donc oui il faut assumer la faute et
apprendre à tenir et pour moi c'est une
école très importante
avez vous un public préféré un public
qui vous serait plus proche je suppose
que le public est aussi différent n'est
ce pas de manière générale il arrive que
le public soit surprenant
quelquefois on arrive dans un pays dans
une ville dans un théâtre on n'a jamais
encore été et on vous y attend déjà
c'est incroyable quelquefois on sort
après le spectacle c'est souvent le cas
au japon en italie c'est arrivé en
france et je ne parle même pas de la
russie est énormément de gens sont là à
vous attendre et vous accueille
ils vous remercient après la prestation
avez vous lu en public qui n'avaient pas
de répondants qui ne vous donnais pas
d'énergie un public impénétrables oui et
tout m'est arrivé mais j'ai toujours cru
que c'était ma faute parce qu'on ne peut
pas tromper le public
si sur scène ce produit du grand art si
on se donne complètement chez qui que ce
soit dans la salle en fin de compte la
glace va se briser ont conquis le public
si on se donne complètement si on se
permet ne serait ce qu'un peu de
négligence
si on s'économise
le public le ressent tout de suite et
leur qu'on pense qu'il vous offre et sa
froideur
cette année votre fondation fait ses 9
ans est-ce que vous avez le temps de
suivre le sort des boursiers y passez
vous beaucoup de temps notre fondation
paix des bourses mensuelles à plus de 20
étudiants
ce que j'aime aussi ce que nous avons un
bel événement pour la fin de l'année et
pour noël c'est un bon dîner de fête
pour les anciens danseurs
je parle toujours des vétérans de la
scène
mais vous savez ce sont des gens dont la
plupart viennent de terminer leur
carrière de danseur ce sont donc des
gens encore jeune et plein de force
nous avons aussi une génération plus
âgée qui formaient le socle du bolchoï à
l'époque soviétique
ces dons un mélange incroyable de
génération qui se rencontrent et
communique c'est une atmosphère
incroyable on dresse une excellente
table tout le monde chante fait des
discours tout le monde adresse ses voeux
ces événements me tient à coeur parce
que je vois ces gens qui ne se voit pas
pendant des années réunir discuter se
raconter les dernières nouvelles de leur
vie la pandémie dont nous avons parlé a
lancé un défi aux vétérans de la scène
comme aux artistes expérimentés comme
artistes amateurs connaissent les jeunes
artistes qui sont en train de commencer
pour qui c'est une importante épreuve le
moment de former la base sont face à un
vide
est ce qu'on peut s'attendre à ce qu'il
y ait pour ainsi dire une sorte de trou
générationnel pour cali car cette
génération n'a pas terminé sa formation
cette année
oui ce n'est pas clair
parce que la période est très difficile
pour les jeunes diplômés qui n'ont eu ni
le concert final et ni les examens pour
lesquels s'étaient préparés tout cela a
été fait comme ça oui pendant tout ce
temps ils se sont entraînés chez eux
pour rester en forme
ça a été très difficile pour les enfants
comme pour les enseignants qui n'en
voyaient parfois pas la moitié pour
s'entraîner et via un écran
il faut une caméra qui tourne autour de
l'artiste parce que l'artiste
surtout si c'est un enfant il faut le
voir de tous les côtés alors que s'il
n'y a qu'un petit écran et que le pauvre
enseignants 1 15 enfants et qu'il doit
tous les voir c'est une catastrophe
ceux qui ont commencé leurs études cette
année ont eu des difficultés aussi je
crois c'est bien c'est les parents font
partie du monde du ballet et se tiennent
l'enfant chez lui s'entraîne avec lui
mais ceux qui ne s'y connaissent pas et
il ya plein d'enfants que ça sauront-ils
rattraper leur retard ou ça pourrait
être un problème critique pour certains
pour l'instant je ne peux pas faire de
diagnostic qui vivra verra
je voudrais bien sûr que tout le monde
rattrape son retard que chaque enfant
reçoit finalement ce qu'il aurait dû
recevoir toutes les connaissances toute
l'attention des enseignants
il est obligatoire qu'il soit sur scène
et ne se limite pas à des classes dans
la salle de bal et jour et nuit il faut
qu'ils entrent dans la grande scène et
montre ce qu'on leur a appris
vous êtes depuis plusieurs saisons
présentatrice de l'émission le grand
ballet
certes elle selon vous à sensibiliser le
public au ballet de manière générale
est ce nécessaire le ballet quand même
un art raffiné fin est il vraiment utile
de le diffuser auprès du grand public
je pense que oui
en regardant le ballet à la télé
beaucoup s'intéressent à cet art en
russie on peut trouver seulement d'un
peu de villes d'été à traquer des mixtes
avec des troupes professionnelles
on peut venir voir un spectacle grâce
aux diffusions à la télé beaucoup de
personnes peuvent voir les spectacles à
l'époque soviétique le ballet et les
concerts étaient très souvent diffusés à
la télé il y avait des concerts au
palais des congrès du kremlin s'est
diffusé dans l'ensemble de l'union
soviétique et à l'époque tout le monde
connaissait galina oulanova maïa
plissetskaïa la popularité n'arrive pas
tout seul il faut s'en occuper
donc je soutiens vraiment ce projet le
grand ballet il ya aussi le projet les
grands et les petits avec des enfants je
crois que c'est très important
c'est beau
et beaucoup de ceux qui ont participé
aux saisons précédentes on perd c'est
leur carrière a démarré leur destin a
changé grâce à ce projet on vous voit on
vous observe
on parle de vous et ça c'est très
important excellent vous aimez quand on
parle de vous non mais en même temps peu
importe ce qu'on dit l'important ce
qu'on dise quelque chose j'aime quand on
dit de votre choses des choses agréables
quand on critique quand on dit des
choses négatives
je peux m'énerver et m'ont forcée mais
une fois calmé je me demande pourquoi
cette personne a eu une telle idée
elle a le droit de penser ans si je
commence à analyser et la fois suivante
j'ai une réaction différente à la
critique du cac
notre profession implique un
apprentissage constant pendant toute
notre vie
près de nous il ya toujours un
enseignant ou plusieurs enseignants qui
nous apprennent des choses en permanence
et on reste toujours des apprentis sur
scène on est une ballerine une étoile
mais dans la salle de répétition on est
toujours élèves
il faut toujours se surpasser chercher
quelque chose de nouveau travailler sur
tous les mouvements techniques ces
fameux 32 fouetter n'arrive pas
facilement
il faut les répéter tous les jours pour
que sur scène le travail ne soit pas
perceptible pour ne voir que la danse et
l'émotion tout cela exige un travail des
répétitions des heures des mois des
années passées dans les salles de
répétition et des litres de
transpiration regardez-vous le ballet
vous même souvent je dirais même très
rarement
pourquoi parce que parce que ce n'est
pas toujours très intéressant pour moi
peut-être parce que quand on est une
jeune ballerine
on veut vraiment voir danser ses
collègues plus âgés ou tu sais mieux
comment on apprend à les regarder
quand on fait déjà partie d'une autre
génération et qu'on a un autre statut
un autre statut pensez vous que les
jeunes viennent voir pour apprendre la
terre ce n'est déjà plus intéressant
pour être honnête nous vous souhaitons
plein de réalisation artistique bien sûr
à propos que souhaitez vous qu'est ce
qui vous manque si on parle de vie
professionnelle avez vous déjà franchi
tous les obstacles
aujourd'hui jacques que chaque jour qui
passe avec joie étant donné la situation
difficile dans laquelle nous nous
trouvons parce que je vois mes collègues
en europe
sans parler des états unis où il n'est
pas sûr que tout revienne à la normale
c'est mort c'est un train de mourir
j'espère que ce n'est pas encore mort
pour le moment
et comme la période n'a pas été encore
trop longue les dents sur sienne essaie
de garder la forme
je comprends que je suis heureuse d'être
ici le gouvernement russe nous soutient
aujourd'hui même si c'est 25% du public
même s'il est difficile de danser
déballer com le lac des cygnes spartacus
la bayadère avec moins de retours
d'applaudissements et de bravos tout à
quoi la scène du bolchoï est habitué
tout à quoi moi personnellement je suis
habitué il y en aura peut-être moins
mais les spectateurs et c'est de nous
soutenir
au lieu d'être mécontent de ce qui se
passe je me dis si je merci nous
continuons à travailler
nous avons l'opportunité de venir tous
les jours un sale
nous avons l'opportunité d'être sur
scène nous gardons la forme tout de
suite après la pandémie
nous avons eu un répertoire fou moderne
classique
nous avons dansé presque tous les
répertoires classiques du bolchoï en
l'espace de ces quelques mois la troupe
s'est tout de suite mobilisé
oui oui et en excellente forme
les artistes peuvent certes dôme est
malade il y à des remplacements tous les
jours pour des raisons différentes
ça peut être des blessures parce que le
répertoire est vraiment vaste des
maladies de manière générale mais cette
idée qu'on continue tout de même à
travailler me fait chaud au coeur
quand je vois que mes collègues en
europe et en amérique sont sans travail
c'est le pire qu'on puisse imaginer
je vous souhaite que les salles soient
remplies à 25% pour ne pas avoir d'
amende mais que les bravos soit entendue
à 125%
merci infiniment merci
[Musique]
vous